so the question oftentimes comes up what
can i as a parent do to help extend much
House literature education beyond what
happens in the classroom
here are a few suggestions on what you
might consider doing at home with your
students first talk about the stories of
their reading in school oftentimes your
student will be reading texts which are
at or slightly beyond their reading
level what that means is that you as a
parent have a great opportunity to ask
them questions about the sorts of things
that they're reading about in school
keep in mind that your students may
struggle to read these texts
independently and by themselves so any
support that you're able to give as a
parent is going to be beneficial to them
start with ask them questions like what
happened in the story ask them to talk
about some of the characters that they
are introduced to ask questions to help
them understand what they're reading
help them get a better sense of what the
narrative is in the story itself ask
them questions like what happened in
your reading today or what happened next
when you ask these sorts of questions
you're encouraging your tile to take a
lot of information and try to boil it
down to a couple of sentences and be
able to articulate those sentences to
you this is an incredibly valuable skill
for any reader and don't limit questions
to those about the narrative feel free
to dive deeper ask them what was the
most surprising or exciting thing that
happened why did that happen why did the
character act in that particular way
when you ask the sorts of questions you
foster a good conversation between you
and your student you want to make sure
that they have the opportunity to enjoy
the story as a whole great book should
foster conversation so feel free to
focus on those things that your student
found particularly interesting in the
story that they just read secondly
encourage a habit of reading in the home
the first best way that you can do this
is simply to read to your child
oftentimes we assume that once a child
turns three or four years old
we Paras don't need to read them anymore
but this can be a very valuable thing
even for older students first off what
do you read stories to your students you
give them the advantage of hearing a
more experienced reader read to them
this exposes them to vocabulary and to
ideas which they might not have been
exposed to otherwise great books of
literature might intimidate them because
they're more difficult to read but that
challenge is lessened when you are
willing to read those kinds of stories
to that audiobooks are a good option
here too so even if you don't have the
opportunity to read your child yourself
feel free to provide them with
unabridged audio books at home that they
might be able to enter into these
stories also get them
keep in mind that the books that they
read in school may be more advanced than
the kinds of books that they can read
comfortably feel free to let them read
books term or at their reading level or
slightly below it we don't want reading
to become a chore we wanted to be
something which the students enjoy so
it's okay if they're reading books which
are a little bit less than what they
typically see in the classroom
additionally make reading a part of your
family culture set time aside in the day
for your family to read together whether
everyone is reading the same book
together or ever and is taking time to
read their own individual books students
who see that reading and something which
is valued by their family are more
likely to enjoy it themselves addition
to reading to them or providing time for
reading dedicate portions of your house
where your child will be more likely to
read a comfortable reading nook or
something along those lines
recently which is very helpful in
fostering their desire to read works of
literature apart from reading books what
can our kids do for younger students
consider having them draw illustrations
of the scenes that you just read about
together as they draw these pictures ask
them questions about what they're
drawing when they finished let this be
an opportunity for them to retell scenes
from the story that they found
particularly memorable
additionally encourage your children to
play act the stories that they reach
I'll often hear stories from teachers
about children who go to the playground
and during the recess time re-enacting
scenes from Robin Hood or King Arthur
while students have this natural
propensity encouraged a sort of thing as
well and feel free to play act with them
in order to help them better understand
these stories finally encourage them to
memorize poetry since arms and stories
that they read whether it's the wind the
Willows or waiting the Pooh if there's a
passage that your child finds
particularly memorable so if we're to
encourage them to memorize and to sing
those songs together with you remember
the important thing is that you're
trying to encourage students who have a
love for reading with that end in mind
don't be afraid to enter to that
experience
you